cualquiera puede morir en cualquier
momento es el título de un nuevo informe
de amnistía internacional que condena el
uso de armas prohibidas por parte de
rusia en ucrania las fuerzas rusas
lanzaron una campaña incesante de
bombardeos indiscriminados contra
jarquín bombardearon barrios
residenciales casi diariamente matando a
cientos de civiles y causando una
destrucción generalizada muchos de los
ataques se llevaron a cabo utilizando
municiones de racimo ampliamente
prohibidas el informe detalla las
pruebas del uso de bombas de racimo por
parte de rusia que son lanzadas por
cohetes cargados de municiones y
dispersadas desde el aire sobre un área
de varios cientos de metros cuadrados
bombardeos a gran escala que han
reducido gran parte de jarc y de
escombros incluyendo edificios parques
infantiles así como lugares de entrega
de ayuda humanitaria
las autoridades locales calculan más de
600 muertos y más de 1200 heridos sólo
en la región de jarquín debido a las
armas indiscriminadas desplegadas por
rusia under international law
según el derecho internacional las
fuerzas están obligadas a distinguir
entre objetivos militares y civiles
también están obligadas a utilizar una
fuerza proporcionada en este caso están
utilizando armas indiscriminadas lo que
significa que no son lo suficientemente
precisas para distinguir entre objetivos
militares y civiles es evidente que
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa en
febrero los fiscales ucranianos afirman
haber abierto más de 12.000
investigaciones sobre supuestos crímenes
de guerra en el país